aujourd'hui il s'agit pour les membres
du collectif 0/4 d'école 0 poison de
montrer l'existence de ceux qui luttent
contre l'empoisonnement s'infiltre dans
toutes les instances capable de donner
du poids à leur démarche citoyenne
l'information publique et donc
stratégique le dossier chlordécone est
chargé le collectif se félicite de
l'obtention du test de dépistage gratuit
mais ce n'est pas gagné il attend des
soutiens politiques à ce niveau là oui
on sent qu'on a été entendu c'est un
petit pas parce qu'il reste tant de
choses à faire et au niveau
effectivement même de nous politique le
coup on a l'impression qu'il ya silence
radio depuis 2012 oui on a vu la montée
et franchement même depuis l'année
dernière
il ya une réelle prise de conscience on
les gens peuvent ne pas être d'accord
pour certaines formes d'action mais
toutes les actions sont bonnes la
crédibilité des revendications du
collectif doit être sans faille
les intervenants ne sont pas choisis au
hasard ce sont les garants de la
fiabilité de leurs requêtes
le docteur jose plage est une des
pionnières en matière de recherche
quant à la contamination chlordécone ces
préconisations concernant la sécurité
sanitaire sont claires aujourd'hui mon à
40% seulement des terres contaminées il
ya 60% non contaminée c'est pas la peine
de dépenser des sommes et des sommes à
essayer de voir si à 20 microgrammes 6 à
10 microgrammes 6 à 5 microgrammes ça
coûte horriblement cher vous avez des
théories n'ont jamais eu de curly caunes
jamais une banane c'est terreur son
cercle on déconne que les produits qui
seront dessus sont zéro pour décoder moi
je crois que c'est ce qu'il faudra
défendre aujourd'hui devant les
autorités et que la population soit
derrière nous aussi à défendre cette
chose une réunion qui se tenait aux
jardins tivoli le collectif 0
chlordécone 0 poison c'est désormais un
réseau l'information et les actions sont
relayés en guadeloupe guyane et
métropole